U
SO MUCH FOR GETTINSTART WITH.USS
OF UK
OUA ME AGOHATOUP 300,000 MILITAY
IMMEDIATY.
>> I NECESRYSUPPORE OF PARTS
--
UNDERLINE THIS I
PLED TALME
HIS, WORDS DEFEND HI>> THIS IS B
SURE THAT THTERRITORIAL
INDEPENDENCE AND FREEDOM WIL
THOSE WHY  WEAPONS, SHOULD
THEIR DIRECTIO
COME A FIERCVEROUKRAINE'S
FORCES, AND A KREMLI
ERENDUMS --
INTERNATL RI EDITOATONCOVERING N
FOR CAK, A
MO
SOUNDS PRETTDRASTIC, BUT
COULD PUTIN HAVE GONE HER? YEAHD
MOBILIZATION WHICH MANDURING
12 HOUDELABEFORE THESPEECH CAMEH
WE ARE THINKING IT MIGHT HAVE
BEEN ON CARDS.
HERE IT SEEMTO BE GOING
SPECIALIZED SK.AT IS INTERESTIN,
--
OND TOVEHIS
GROUPS HAVE BEEN GOING INTO
TO FRONT LINE ANDNPRS
EXCHANGE AMNESTY.
S CLEAR ATHIS POINT
WHERE THISL
MOBILIZATION PAINTS THAT THI
OT ABOUTING STUDENTSHE UNIR
ORDINARUCTS YRCINTHEM TO THE FT
CONSCRIPTION.
RHETORICNTO ACTUAL PEOPLE ONE OG
CONTROPROBLEMSSO ALL THE PROBLSE
TO B--
A LARGE NUMBERINVIISENALIT OF
ESS IN RUSSIA.
RSINMS OF WHAT HAPPENS IN THE
WEE ANE
AT, EAUTIN DID
RGATS OFRUIA WAS IN FA T
NUCLEAR WEAPONS, THAT FURSEONS S
ESTIONHE MIGHT USE
CTIOD
, AND IS BIG CHANGINHEOCE.PLT TE
TERRITORIAL INTEGRY OW SING,
--ITS ERS MAY
.
SAID ABOUT NUCLEARPONS, BUT,HECE
PROCEDURE OVER THEO
DAYS,  AREAS THAT HAVE
BEENUPIED BY PRO 201AND THE
Y OCPIED GO-AHEALMY WILL AND
ALMOST WILL A
APPARENT W BE PART OF
RUSSIA.
NOT A VOTE WAY
THIS IS HAPPENING UNDER --
ARE NOW PARTF .MAY CAUSE
THNG DYN
HERE WHERS GOING TO HAVE TO DSE
MA ISSUES AND IAL
MOBILIZA HA
S GOING TO CHANGE
ICS AT
HAMAKE
SL THIS STAGE.S, AND STILL SE
AND,SSIBLY TRY AND
REFERENDUM.
SOIG MOVE HE BY MOSCOW,
T  BIG AS THEY COULD
POTENTIALLY HAVE MADE,RTSIA
ST IS IRO
KRISTEN?S,AVSS RATHER THANPOSIT
MANY PEOPLE UALLYBE SEENCH DO Y
RCIS CALL.
THAT THAMALL IS HIGH LY
OF S IN RAVE ALREADY BEEN  T T.
REMEMBERTHE UNITED STAS
ENGGESTED AS M
FLICTED UPON RUSSIA.
THAT IS ED.
UNTHEY GET THOSEMBERS FROM, BUT.
S ING VERYIRREGUFO PUSHES THE ME
ARE N UNITS,
THEYIA
SEPARATIST REPUB OF LUHANSK
D DONETSK TH BASICALLY
CONTROLLED OCCUPIED BY
RUSSIAN FORCES.
THEY ARE MERCENARIES,
MIX, ONE THAT
IAL MOBILIZATION, SOLVE THE
MAER POSSIBLY
CHANGE THE IN RUSSIAT W  POPULAN
D
THENSSHENGE --L T
BATTLEFIELD H
ATROHE WRO
CTION FOR RUSSIA.
TEK PATON, WALSH LIVE IN
FROM LONDON, SO, CLARE, HOW AREH
ENHER PEOPLE
TIN?
>>S AR
N PRETTY B OWALLACE THAT THIS IF
FROM THE DEFENSIVE VERY HAS
THRESIDEBREAKING UP HIS OWN PROS
NOT TO THE
ONL
ANNETIONF  UKRAINE
ARE AN ADMISSION THAT HIS
HE SAY CONTINUING NO AMOUNT
PROPAGHIDE THE FACNE
AMBASSADORRI, ASWAR, A SILM E
D FASPEECH WAS STILL,RONZATION S
UNITED SS E RUSSIA'S CLAIM TOPON
TEOR CONTINUE TO
AN UKRAINE FOR AS LONG
PRAND THE RUIADEFENSE SECRTOF
ONE NO UBUT WITHTHE WEST.
ADVICE TPRENZE--ID
A TWEET SAYING, THIS IS TY OF R
THOUGHT THIS WOULD BE A
ENDED UP GETTING ONE
MOBILIZATION TO S
OBADESERTION.
NG IS STGOG
TOLAA
THE PROBLEM FOR UKRAINE AND ALL
OF THIS IS THAT TH LELSIGNALS TD
KRISTE>> PRECISELYOS LONDON FOR.
THANK YOU.
LMORNING,
ONLY GOING TO BE ADDRESSING ONE
PARTICULAR WHO WILL NOT
ROOMVLCNN'RICHARD ROSS AS MORE.R
PRESIDENT TO ADJUSHIS
SPNG UN GENERAL
T THAT IS WHAT JENDONE INSTEAD E
IONAL U.S.LOT HI WHICH WAS
IN FACE SEVERA
ENOF OFFICIALS SAY PRESIDENT
BIDEN WILL CONDEMN RUSA
NGLY FOR ITS IAS
UKRAINE, AND ALSO COMMENT ON
SECURITYOU
WORLD LDE
R SPEECHES OE FRENCH PRESIDENT,D
RUSSIA FORN, AND
D THOSRE TRYING
RAAFFAIR.
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
[INTERPRETER]
THOSE WHKEEPINTODAY ACTUALLY AR
COMPLICIT WITH THE CAUSE OF
PERIAL
THS
T ORDER.
TRETRE'NOBL[END OAN
A REFERENDUM IN EAN DAY.
ALSO MET WITH IRAN